[Music]
oh what is going on YouTube now everyone
has been asking this question a lot hey
David how you do the Asian accent now I
personally don't know if I should give
you all this power because I taught one
man had to do it and he just won't stop
doing it all the time apparently when
one white boy does it it's like the most
hilarious thing on earth and Asian women
just flock to him like a mock to a flame
d man you look so good and my God he's
ethnic in today's Asian accent lesson we
are going to learn how to do a Korean
one oh these a good one step one
misplace the word the anywhere you can
for some reason to Korean people the
word ' is like the hardest word to place
in a sentence and because we can't
figure out where to put the word ' the
whole sentence gets messed up like a
train wreck in the process for example
in English can you pass the fork please
in Korean P the PO can you pass to me
step number two three letters Korean
people can't pronounce f l and V the F
turns into a p l turns into an r and the
V turns into a b if you ever wanted to
piss off a cre person you just metant
just introduce yourself with a name that
has all those letters in it hey what's
up how's it going my name is um Vivian
flawless
f oh that's the
[Music]
uhan
peder she step number three when in
doubt add a ridiculous amount of
syllables to your words for some damn
reason we always add extra syllables to
a word that need be for example in
English excuse me in Korean
[Music]
me step number four when in doubt add an
in to a word every now and then for
example in English hello I have a big
problem in Korean I having the big
problem step number five end any word
with a typical sound
of and place the word with the letter S
at the end of a word anytime you want
what do I mean by that in English good
luck friend I hope you have a better day
in
Korean I hope you have a better better
day and finally step six add a random
loud Excel with the word in front of
every sentence in English hey buddy long
time no see in Kore yeah buddy tast a
long time no see and that's about it
folks just remember to Jumble all your
words together and bastardize the
English language and you should be good
to go just remember these tips and as
fast as you can say kimchi you'll be
talking just like this yeah I have to
hear Pro the pean that the pr is
actually not the amazing place
to that's
crazy praise the
Jesus girl you're so fine yeah sto my
heart way back when we was just
kids stay on my
mind I will P your Braes in a run away
like boys
do
[Music]
ladies prepare
yourself